Why is it not good to take iodine? I thought that it helped protect against radiation.
I remember when the Chernobyl scare happened with the damage to Chernobyl,
and I remember when the tsunami damaged the nuclear power plant in Japan.
And a lot of nutritious were saying you should get iodine and start taking iodine because radiation is going to be most damaging to your thyroid glands.
So if you get radiation through food that you're eating because it's some tainted food or radiation because of where you're living.
And typically this was talking about people on the west coast as the waves of radiation and radioactive waste was coming from Japan,
coming over the ocean to people in Alaska and the northwest United States.
A lot of nutritious were saying to take iodine to protect your thyroid.
But there was a lot of information out about if there's ever a nuclear holocaust of any kind, it would be good to take iodine to protect your thyroid.
And there is some truth to that.
Your thyroid needs iodine badly in order for it to produce its two made hormones.
T4 and T3 is the active thyroid hormone but it mainly produces T4, then that changes to the active T3 in the gut.
And so it is dependent upon iodine and if there are other radioactive minerals present, it will have a predilection to go to the thyroid and replace it itself in place of iodine and it can cause thyroid cancer.
In the case of radiation toxicity, thyroid cancer is one of the more common cancers.
So there is some truth if you're exposed to radiation like in a nuclear holocaust, taking some iodine can be helpful.
So however, taking iodine exogenously, we need an outside of just what you would be getting in your food.
And typically that would be in the form of potassium iodide in supplements can be harmful to your thyroid because too much iodine is going to increase the risk of sparking an autoimmune attack on thyroid food.
In fact, there's multiple studies that show that people with hypothyroidism, primary hypothyroidism, taking iodine because that was the old idea.
Back in the 1960s on, it was thought that iodine deficiency was a major cause of hypothyroidism.
Not that it can't be a piece of that, but it isn't a major cause and with that theory, iodine supplementation was really pushed.
It's still pushed by a lot of uninformed nutritionalists and carpractors and naturopaths.
And it is causing Hashimoto so a person can have primary hypothyroidism, not autoimmune thyroid, and take iodine taking that that's going to help their thyroid.
They can actually have some symptom relief by taking iodine.
If you can take the long, iodine for a prolonged period of time, it can create an immune attack on the thyroid.
And there are studies that show that people that do that with primary hypothyroidism, 100% of the people, they have developed Hashimoto.
So that's an autoimmune thyroid where you have elevated TPO or viral globulin antibodies.
So it's not recommending. So I do not recommend people taking iodine supplementation for a prolonged period of time.
Taking a short term for different reasons is certainly make sense, but taking it long for a prolonged period of time, taking that you're doing good for your thyroid, or going doing good to prevent any radioactive attack on your thyroid is not really wise.
So the struggle is you're trying to find a mineral supplement if you are trying to find a mineral supplement that doesn't have added potassium iodine.
It's very difficult out there.
That effect where we private labels one that we can no longer get as of this week.
And that was one of the only ones that was on the market that didn't have that. Now, there are a few other ones that don't have iodine.
I also make it because I'm looking for a mineral supplement that doesn't have iodine and doesn't have copper.
So it's safe for my cancer patients. Now, there's a few that I would approve of that don't have iodine or have a or a food based mineral that may have a little bit of iodine, which is at a food base, not at a potassium iodine.
And they have just a little bit of copper that's at a food base that isn't just a copper supplementation that's added.
So as we are scrambling to find the right supplement for our patients for that, I do want to remind because we have a lot of patients that don't necessarily follow my recommended and they're taking supplements that maybe I wouldn't approve of.
Approved of, but you're listening to me, but I'm just telling you, taking supplements, taking minerals with added copper.
If it's not a food based like you're taking greens first, that has copper in it. Yeah, but it's just food based, what would be in the food you're eating, it's not added copper.
Oh, it does have iodine. Yeah, but it's food based. It's not added iodine. So if you're taking a mineral and you're paying for a mineral that's adding potassium iodine, adding copper and you have cancer, you are increasing your risk of cancer growth because of the added copper and you're increasing your risk of Hashimoto's because of the added iodine. So I just don't think that's wise.
So do beware of mineral supplements as a cancer patient. Even if you, oh, my daughter takes this, she's not a cancer patient. So can she take added copper? Well, yes, but copper toxicity is also very common among non cancer patients, especially when we look at your genetics.
Many of you have, I've gone over your genetics and I've shown that you have issues with seruloclasm with other copper transport genes, which increases one's risk. So those are not uncommon, whether that increases one's risk for copper toxicity. So we're getting access copper and you're taking supplements with added copper.
That increases one's risk for copper toxicity because many people are as efficient. So when they're not absorbing their zinc, if they're taking zinc, so they have a deficiency of zinc, and they have excess copper.
And then you can get access copper in the tissue. It can be a cause of joint issues, muscle issues,
arthritis problems, degenerative joint issues, all sorts of cognitive issues, and general malaise and fatigue. So copper toxicity is a real thing that you want to be aware of too. So even if you don't have cancer, I don't think that a person should be taking a lot of excess copper.
So that's thing to think about too. And certainly, if you don't have cancer, you don't want to be taking iodine because you could end up with thyroid issues. And Hashimoto is the number of one autoimmune disease currently going, and I think a big part of that, or at least a piece of that has to do with the rhodious thought that everybody should be taking iodine.